where do you shop for clothes do you
have everything made for you or do you
go and shop for clothes people ask me
because I'm taller and I got super long
kooky legs and I can't just walk in
anywhere and say give me those pants
right there because I it just you have
extra material that has to be added to
your life sometimes yeah oh I bet unless
you go to big and tall I don't quote a
big and tall
let's just let's nothing against people
that go to big and tall but I don't John
Tesh has to go to big and tall I know I
don't go to big and tall but I can it's
just I met the kind of the maximum you
know I got very tall you're so tall I
mean you feel self-conscious I'm some
kind of freak or so people who are
taller should have to pay more for their
clothes and I think people like me you
should get a discount where do you where
do you okay so where do you get your
click what do you I've gone got kids a
lot to get my clothes you can adapt kids
of course the jackets they're perfect
they're cheaper don't you think we
should get you should get paid more I go
to the circus to get my clothing I get
the clothes that the guys with the
stilts wear those pants that's what I
wear favorite things about Isis and when
we stand next to each other people like
we just stand near each other we look
like people that don't even come from
the same planet
[Music]
it's funny cuz my hips yeah are up here
yeah I love a circus wedding yeah when I
use a urinal and button my shirt it's
ridiculous deodorant okay we're gonna
take a little break
you